in liverpool big problem
massive problem humongous problem i got
a job going on in liverpool and my
builders
left my builders walked out of sight
they're going bankrupt
i haven't finished i got tight deadlines
i'm very unhappy
[Music]
do you not go to liverpool or north
world unless i say so yeah
i've got about two weeks i need to get
this
he was invoicing me for stuff i was
paying and then he was telling his work
man
oh sami was not paid he had and then
wasn't paying his voice
hey good to see you guys how you doing
very well oh good
yeah very well hey alan how's it going
mate
what's that wonderbar oh good
yeah my goodness what a disaster right
yeah appreciate you coming out mark
what's that even as weeks i'm
landscaping yes everybody
oh no is it oh my goodness terrible
really i'm leaving
yes that's the last ticks i received
often
do you not go to liverpool or north
world unless i say so yep yeah
and i hadn't been for a week when i got
that
that was the last fix i got off him oh
goodness joker anyway we're glad mark
came in to save the day
how's it going it's going okay you know
just don't touch the walls
all right corporate printing all right
cool man upstairs but some of it's off
oh wow painting started oh wow good
the paint makes it look a lot better
doesn't it
the paint makes that's a lot better i
mean
so basically um i called you up and said
i've got about two weeks i need to get
this replay finished
and then you've suddenly miraculously
pulled oh it's not being easy let me
tell you that's why
and in exchange i'm gonna buy him a big
drink
oh wow wait the paint is making it look
way better isn't it
just to make it better the way it was um
oh
[Music]
it's all happening fast now yeah
oh
[Music]
fabulous it's really coming together oh
wow
you've got the bath in
genius i wish i'd just used mark from
the beginning
mark is the man
i'm really happy with how it's how it's
looking
it's looking close isn't it yeah dude
you've done an incredible job
have you brought this one up i don't
know
what's that needed to be clear i don't
know how it's being changed
you
so the last builders they were just
joking yeah it's really weird because
they've worked on like 15 jobs for us
i think what it is i think the guy who's
saying who's
who you give the way to i think he's a
building he's not on site so he's just
giving away
sort of running the jobs yeah
so i'm going to just bring that down a
little turn a little bulkhead above that
bit yeah bring it down and across
yeah i mean to take that out and patch
it all in at night it's gonna be an
animation yeah
i love the back as well
yeah yeah really nice really really
really nice
yeah it will be nice i think you're
right there more has happened in the
last three days
in the last three months yeah it's crazy
isn't it yeah
absolutely crazy how i thought
i thought about those
[Music]
honestly i'm really grateful amazing job
so far
so um so how many days weeks do you
think is going to be before it can be
fully finished
well i went to the carpeting by saturday
i went to canada this is
softly coming
this week well he's put the stoppers on
and off the uh
this week so you were in the competition
on the 19th
i wanted the carpet stand this week here
do you think when did
it's going to be next week now because
the access is still running cables under
the floor and
yeah so yeah brill
have you managed to pull in all the all
the different people
plasterers joiners painters decorators
carpet fitters i don't know actually
just
uh i think a few people only want so use
them up for me credits one
so a few people when you put it so now i
i have a big one
yeah great these doors is nice nice
doors
yeah they're nice yeah yeah they
launched
well these boys seem really on it man
mate if it wasn't for you i would be
well and truly
screwed well pretty good aren't we yeah
honestly well and truly screwed
i think just fine just finding just
finding one trades person
just finding a decorator to come this
week
a carpet fitter a joiner a plasterer
like electrician
a plumber yeah they've even got my son
in there doing all the air
hunting all the rubbish oh dude just off
shelf you know they're
in stock so um that's why we've
got these ones you can't get other ones
i think this one
that one's more kitchen on bathrooms
maybe this one for kitchen this one for
bathroom
got one kitchen yeah does that work yeah
yeah
yeah finally the fun bit
the fun bit of choosing the colors for
the paint rather than chasing
electricians and stuff in terms of
picture walls there
um i mean it probably makes sense it was
a new door coming as well oh brilliant
yeah oh
look we painted these things on the
outside my goodness
it does look better
looks good so there we go
giving it a facelift finishing the final
i would be
done i would be screwed if i didn't if i
didn't know mark
that's why you need uh you need backup
people you know
your network is your network and without
my network being able to do this it
would be dwindling my net worth very
quickly
don't work with bad builders and uh
i think that's the moral of the story
all right let's go
damn
you